l'an dernier yves embauche une compagnie
d'entretien de cogneuses d'issue du
résultat il décide de ne pas rappeler
d'entreprises cette année les un jour en
revenant du boulot surprise son gazon a
été traitée et dans sa boîte aux lettres
une facture
il prend contact avec la compagnie on
croyait lui répondons qu'il désirait les
mêmes services que l'an passé livres
doivent payer cette facture
il n'y avait aucune clause de
renouvellement automatique dans son
contrat et la loi de la protection du
consommateur est très clair à ce sujet
un commerçant n'a pas le droit de vous
faire payer pour un service que vous
n'avez pas demandé
soyez donc vigilants cette pratique
douteuse aussi comme un la mauvaise
herbe